alors que les équipes de l'émission les
anges de la télé réalité était en
tournage pour une nouvelle saison du
programme à la réunion voilà qu'en
quelques minutes tout a dégénéré créant
une gigantesque polémique aujourd'hui
qu'on fasse attention lorsqu'on met les
pieds à la réunion ne se disent pas on
arrive en pays conquis bédié le maire de
la commune de saint-andré à la réunion
ainsi que sa famille aurait d'été en été
agressé par plusieurs candidats du
programme dans l'hôtel créolia ou une
sombre histoire de photos prises sans
l'autorisation des candidats une affaire
dont son avocat nous parler hier sur
notre plateau on sait évidemment
inadmissible et c'est la raison pour
laquelle mon client s'est constituée
partie civile et ira au bout de la
procédure judiciaire
un événement qui semble avoir beaucoup
choqué juste après l'altercation durée
bédié avait demandé à la production de
l'émission et aux candidats de quitter
l'île en raison de leur comportement
déplacé
une version que certains candidats
contre 10 aujourd'hui plus je sais ce
qui s'est passé mot pour mot exactement
les faits et tout ce soir raphaël pépin
candidats des anges est avec nous pour
nous parler de cette affaire et nous
donner en exclusivité sa version des
faits alors raphaël merci d'être là en
tout cas ce soir pour avoir d'autres
versions parce que c'est vrai qu'on
donne on veut la version des deux camps
ya on a eu l'avocat de joe et bédié donc
le maire de saint-andré de la réunion et
aujourd'hui on a aussi des nouvelles
images à vous montrer des nouvelles
vidéos de ce qui se serait passé
regardez regardez première
[Applaudissements]
voilà ces vidéos on en a d'autres
raphaël alors vous vous connaissez très
bien les protagonistes de cette affaire
bien sûr
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous avez été victime d'acharnement moi
moi je suis ici pas pour essayer d'être
enfin pour essayer du moins d'être le
plus juste possible sur les vidéos vous
nous montrez aujourd'hui je vois deux
candidates et l'arrêté je vois la femme
de ricardo qui est tout à droite en
train de de bouger je vois deux
candidates et réalité ne pas bouger
justement et je vois des gens que je ne
connais pas en train de frapper
certainement quelqu'un je peux pas dire
que c'est ricardo puisque je ne le vois
pas j'arrive pas à me rends compte
mais à aucun moment je vois trois camps
de latéralité baraqué et musclée de
taper sur qui que ce soit alors raphaël
quelle est la version parce que moi j'ai
une version qui dit et j'ai vu vraiment
beaucoup de versions tournée qui dit que
ricardo et leonard vous n'est pas que le
maire sa fille et sa femme prenne ses
leurs enfants en photo mais c'est pas
vrai du tout ricardo et neruda ont
accepté les photos ça fait trois jours
qui sont dans le même hôtel
ils ont accepté les photos d'accord sauf
que à un moment donné la production donc
c'est la jeune fille qui a été cité donc
je dirai pas son prénom mais qui fait
partie de la production a demandé au
maire sans savoir que c'était maire de
ne pas faire fuiter les photos et les
vidéos qu'ils avaient prise sur les
réseaux sociaux pour essayer de garder
un maximum de 2 de secret professionnel
ccp alors là la version que vous donnez
vous la version pareil donc il lui
aurait dit non mais ici on fait ce qu'on
veut
b et de ce qui a été dit voilà alors
c'est quoi l'histoire
en gros le maire et sa femme auraient
répondu plus ou moins en disant écoute
ici t'es pas chez toi
on fait ce qu'on veut et si on veut les
diffuser ses photos et ses vidéos on
fait ce qu'on veut
voilà ce qui s'est dit et de là c'est
une petite la femme de la productrice et
une petite femme d'un mètre cinquante
d'accord mais quand évidente ans à elle
vient pour dire au monsieur écoutez
c'est pas comme ça qu'on parle à une
femme voilà c'est une dame de la
productrice à fait juste son travail et
de la santé n'est sur des mots d'oiseaux
et ça a pris des ampleurs tout
simplement mais ricardo aujourd'hui et
neruda et les deux autres personnes qui
sont inculpés apparemment n'ont
absolument pas pourquoi le maire aurait
tout inventé sur
moi je dis pas qui est ce qu'il ya une
version vous dites qu apparemment ça ne
plaît pas tellement que les candidats
soient là bas oui et que les réunionnais
avait été invisible n'est pas très envie
de voir ces candidats de télé réalité il
ya deux partis apparemment de ce que moi
j'ai cru comprendre à la réunion il ya
des gens qui sont très contents de voir
les anges arrivé il ya d'autres gens qui
sont pas contents mais il ya des
réunionnais qui ont dû être déçus par ce
qui s'est passé aussi les pauvres qui
éveille qui se faisait une joie mais
vous croyez que les enjeux aujourd'hui
la marque les enjeux et moi et qui tout
le monde qui regarde la télé vous croyez
qu'ils sont ravis de ce qui s'est passé
est ce que vous pensez que nous on est
content de ce qui s'est passé sur lequel
sont ok l'état de neruda et qu'un
d'aujourd'hui n'est oda et ricardo
aujourd'hui ils sont tristes mais ils
sont attristés ils sortent de d'affaires
qui ont été réglés par la justice
d'accord pour qui quand j'ai entendu
dire oui ils sont mais ils sont encore
dans des affaires machin les affaires
qu'ils ont eues auparavant ça a été des
affaires réglées par la justice jugée où
ils ont été plaidées non coupable
d'accord aujourd'hui on les remet dans
une affaire pour laquelle ils n'ont pas
demandé d'y être et malheureusement
évidemment ils sont ils sont meurtris
parce qu'on dit oui les ans je n'aurais
pas dû l'a recruté
il me semble que la dernière émission
qui effet ricardo est une évidence c'est
quand même les marseillais et vous savez
que dans chaque émission de télé réalité
qu'on fait on nous demande le
confinement judiciaire oui mais c'est ce
qu'on vous demande voilà il ya aussi et
on le dit dans les émissions de télé
réalité comme ça vous êtes tous se sont
bien souvent des bastons il ya souvent
des voix là ça se voit ça se bat souvent
ça chauffe souvent non c'est ce que ça
fait partie de dd du scénario qui vous
est donné alors il n'y a pas de scénario
donné il n'y a jamais de bagarre c'est à
dire à part du moment où on lève la main
sur un candidat que tu es 4 millions
d'abonnés louvain abonnés le premier qui
lèvent la main
la production ne cherche pas à savoir le
pourquoi du comment cette personne là
est exclue que ce soit dans n'importe
quelle télé réalité secret story
les marseillais les anges la villa des
kurdes arrivés dans toutes les émissions
c'est la même chose tu lèves la menthue
et c'est ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs
alors vous avez juste moi j'ai plusieurs
infos premières informations que l'adil
raphaël le tournage des anges à la
réunion c'était un vrai événement sur
place avec des gens pour et des gens
contre la fausse tard que le maire il
était fermement opposé à ce tournage
salle exaspéré que les anchois sa classe
il y avait une guerre entre lui et le
préfet qui a donné son accord pour leur
donner son accord et quelque part le
maire était bien content que
il y ait cette polémique après la baston
c'est la première fois que j'ai et la
deuxième information que j'ai c'est sur
les personnes qui étaient sur place qui
vont donner des infos on a dit que le
tournage était annulé hier
en fait il n'est pas annulé la
production essayé d'annuler l'annulation
ça voulait dire en fait qu'ils essayent
de refaire la banque mondiale de l'eau
chaude non mais en fait on vous disait
hier on vous a révélé que ça coûtait
très cher ça pouvait coûter jusqu'à 500
mille euros l'annulation c'est un
désastre ils vont adultes et
l'annulation des nations ce qui veut
dire qu'ils veulent quand même tourner à
la réunion il doit prendre la décision
dans les heures qui viennent et ils
cherchent à faire le tournage coûte que
coûte est ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont
des chances d'aller à la suite à
l'annulation
non parce que c'est un désastre pour eux
de perdre autant d'argent quand vous en
remettez nous permet 500000 euros sur la
boîte de production comment on fait ils
vont d'ailleurs ça va leur coûter 500
millions euros donc ils veulent tourner
coûte que coûte
et là il faut qu'on ait les anges
émerger nous a confirmé cette saison la
saison ils vont la faire coûte que coûte
ils voulaient des affaires dans un autre
pays que la france ils voulaient changer
de pays et là en fait ils sont en train
d'essayer de garder le tournage à la
réunion parce que ça peut être trop cher
d'annuler ce désastre sur les accords
oui on va faire compléter j'ai eu des
infos aussi apparemment il y avait le
fils du maire qui était à la table et
afriqiyah qui a bientôt avec était avec
ses copines et apparemment ils vont
demander à faire des photos et c'est de
là que serait monté le ton effectivement
c'est parce que la production dont et
gentiment et apparemment vraiment
gentiment d'arrêter de faire des photos
pour les ont que des raisons plutôt
évoqué que ces mots des producteurs des
anges vous qui vous appeler alors j'ai
eu effectivement devenir des anges je
les aimais g2g parce que le producteur
des gens j'ai appelé tout le monde pour
pleurer voilà la raison pour eux mais
c'est maintenant ça mais c'est qu'ils
chantent wade briquet qui vous a entre
autres mais j'ai dû deux personnes et
non non j'ai entre autres les géants
tonique et je sais que cantonal récappé
tout le monde entier ajouté moi je vous
dis on savait découvert d'autres
personnes apparemment c'est monter dans
les tours à cause du fils du maire qui
le peuvent pas voir étape est le premier
et ricardo aurait pris des coups et il
aurait passé un moment un séjour à
l'hôpital il est apparemment abîmé il a
repris une chaise sur la tête
visiblement ce n'est pas aussi clair bon
on va attendre que ce soit réglé mais ce
n'est pas aussi clair que ce qui a
expliqué le maire et sa femme ont trois
jours tout cas c'est la dernière partie
alors m radio aujourd'hui le maire et sa
femme se sont vu prescrire trois jours
d'itt été aussi oui procureur bagarre
donc bagarre il ya des biens sur le parc
mais je - raphaël ans je mets en doute
personne mais il semblerait aussi que il
a été reconnu coupable ya quelques
années vous savez un nez ou da et
ricardo sur par le tribunal
correctionnel d'avignon pour violences
envers de fans
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a été
nommé c'est pas que si ce temps là ça
veut dire hier moi quand je regarde tpm
puisque j'ai regardé hier jean temps
plein de choses la première question qui
a été posée par géraldine maillet c est
ce qu il avait pris de la drogue et de
l'alcool
c'est consternant c'est ce qu'avait
laissé entendre le maire oui mais ce
qu'il ya dedans mais on avait la version
du maire aujourd'hui la ya plein de gens
qui vont dire ah bah non ils sont
maintenant ils sont du côté des idées
voilà la téléralité aujourd'hui le vrai
problème qui a six essais c'est vraiment
stigmatiser on est dans une case
aujourd'hui on se dit que les gens de
télé a été cédée violent c'est des cas
mais c'est des alcools y ait ce cas la
drogue et de l'alcool de riz sur
l'épaule alors en dernier ja ne mentez
pas je congèle avais je connais la
vérité je vais vous dire la vérité moi
oui évidemment qu'il ya de l'alcool y
est un verre d'alcool par candidat c'est
ça plus étonnant non non non je veux
dire d'alcool c'est un candidat face à
elle je t'adore mais là tu monde
alors moi je bois pas d'alcool je ne me
drogue pas j'ai aucun prétexte
ouais moi je vous le dis je sors de ton
âge il ya deux semaines d'accord il ya
un verre d'alcool d'accord autorisé
autorités ne rappelle que l'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé non par jour par
soir et non pas des verres d'alcool
toutes les deux les québécois qui douche
[Rires]
on faisait la lorraine alors oui mais on
va pas en me disant le journal sans
voile sur les ans j'avais des séquences
sans citer de noms mais sachez pas mais
moi j'étais le bouton pour six personnes
feront sûrement d'accord et ce qui
advient drogue mais il ya de la drogue
ça s'est il était alors des gens
évidemment il ya des candidats qui
prennent de la drogue d'accord et ça me
revient pas il y en a qui ont ramé
l'alabama
c'est la première à presles moi je vais
vous dire je vous dise je suis désolé
moi le l'exemple de dire que oui en a
qui prennent la drogue moi je suis
désolé je suis producteur de l'émission
s'il ya une personne mais je ferai moi
durant de la drogue raymond chopin et
bonbons puis on met tout raid est
proposé
merlin tu viens de le dire toi même je
te tutoie tu vas me dire toi même qu'il
ya de la drogue et d'alcool qui avait un
verre d'alcool et certaines villes il ya
des gens pacsés toit est certainement
qu'il ya des gens qui prennent de la
drogue
mais si il y a des gens qui prennent de
la drogue en aucun cas la production est
au courant de ça d'accord c'est comme si
vous rentrez chez vous vous avez
exigeant vous rentrez chez vous 26 il
est rejoint dans la poche ils fument
sont jouées en cachette
bien évidemment on n'est pas juste
raphaël nous on n'a rien contre eux mais
oudin sont les satellites ont bien géré
nos dépens du fc les cards oeneo
d'achever je les ai souvent défendu hier
je voulais juste la version de monsieur
le maire parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
été choqués ce gamin un monsieur de
soixante trois ans sa femme aussi lé
voilà ils sont plutôt jeunes et donc on
a été choqués et les téléspectateurs
aussi par la violence des images qu'on a
vu maintenant on veut juste savoir la
vérité
et voilà chaque jour il ya un nouveau un
nouvel une belle nouvelle version qui
sort mais aux côtés des images mais on
aperçoit aucun candidat de télé-réalité
lever les mains sur qui que ce soit sur
cette vidéo
qu'est-ce qui se baladent telle est la
question moi je ne connais pas ces gens
là rien mais à aucun moment je vois un
candidat de télé réalité et vous pouvez
demander à qui que ce soit tous ceux qui
regardent latérite et reconnaissent là
je vois un candidat avec le short orange
est en train de tourner il met 0 coup je
vois neruda à droite elle met 0 coup à
aucun moment sur cette vidéo
j'arrive à avoir un candidat de télé
réalité le qui portent des coups sur
quelqu'un qui vous avez essayé d'avoir
des ou d'art alors maintenant je me suis
exprimé hier parce que je voulais avoir
la version des deux parties alors neruda
n'a pas trop voulu s'escrimer à ma juste
expliqué qu'en fait ça elle allait être
détruite par cet acharnement qu'elle
ressent elle comme un acharnement et que
justement moi mon avis c'est qu'on
devrait pas en pâtir de ce qui s'est
passé dans le passé un moment donné il
ya eu la juve et la justice a été a été
fait
bon bah maintenant c'est pas parce que
ces gens là où un passif ou quoi que ce
soit qu'il faut absolument leur jeter la
pierre
il faut entendre les deux parties et
malheureusement la semaine par leurs
paroles jb a fait ça loeb après l'es10 y
en a qui vont appliquer nicolas faire un
corps voulait dire quelque chose juste
oui oui mais ce que je vous ai demandé à
monsieur sait comment expliquer une
telle violence paris c'est ça fait quand
même très violent vous avez vous avez
comme les onze jours une responsabilité
sur un public tout ce que vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui vous suivent sur
les réseaux sociaux dont il ya un moment
donné il va falloir que quelqu'un prenne
la parole et s'exprimer le maire aussi
ils vont la production moyenne inscrits
à poser à guillaume genton pourquoi la
production s'est pas exprimé non mais
sans rigoler ou là parce que c'est
extrêmement masse en fait la
problématique vous êtes ses émissions
c'est qu'avant la télé réalité c'était
d'éternité d'enfermement dont vous aviez
un contrôle qui viennent s'ils veulent
antoine aymeric et avec plaisir le
pourrait bien amener sur le permanent
sera bonifie belle personne des quais
une embrouille dans secret story des
cabines baston la production de voiliers
sa sortie directement là le problème
entre une vie meilleure que oui c'est
bien sûr qu'il avait déplacé le problème
c'est que entre guillemets vous êtes
dans la vrai dire quoi servent qu'à des
jours où je crois que c'est un jour par
semaine le dimanche vous êtes off ça
reste des adultes c'est pas des enfants
qu'on a mentionné envie de boire 6 envie
de prendre l'air
vous appelez la production m'a appelé
oui j'ai eu des gens et sur place
la production voudrais rappeler mais non
wouah les chéris moi je vais poser mais
j'ai un stylo ici et j'espère que vous
allez me répondre mais pas vraiment là
prenez simplement est ce que vous êtes
cynique sincèrement est-ce que vous
allez série moi je le dis aux terribles
capteurs moi je pense que benjamin
castaldi
le producteur des anges vous a mis un
petit coup de pression vous appelez
fallu on vous raconte en lice lors je
peux me défendre
oui a exigé alors j'ai appris hier soir
et je peux vous montrer j'ai surmonté
les représentants de l'émission entonne
un kit pour qu'ils me racontent docteur
ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'effectivement on avait une émission
qui était relativement à charge c'est
normal c'était la boc étaient là bien
sûr aujourd'hui même appelé antoine que
je connais bien et que tu vois ce qui
s'est passé il a été d'abord il était
extrêmement perturbé pas expliquer tout
ce qui s'est passé alors il s'était déjà
fait deux heures donc je vais en mai ces
mois passés qu'est ce qui s'est passé
lors 8 qu'est ce qui s'est passé me dit
voilà ça s'est passé
et voilà la bague est réparti les
premiers boutons rabat et sont censés
menacer et c'est l'histoire de deux
photos ils ont été agacés que les
parents les copains et les amis du fils
du maire prenne des photos ça a été
assez assez vindicatif dans les propos
andy webb des défilés des mères etc en
les traitant de plusieurs noms d'oiseaux
peu importe
et apparemment les premiers coups ont
été portés n'ont pas parlé konaté vérité
mais par les copains qui sur les
candidats ces gardes qui s'était cognée
marquée par le par le fils du maire il
il a fait un séjour à l'hôpital il a
pris une chaise sur la tête il a une
tête apparemment contusionné donc moi il
met moins 10 hd coûte m'a très bien
comme ça je pourrais le raconter demain
chez cyril expliquer ce qui s'est passé
maintenant c'est la version du
producteur il est très embarrassé
effectivement il est forcément dans
une mère de noir on va se mettre à sa
place et c'est qu'elle permet
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on leur donne la
balle à ses très bons mais on se bat on
parle donc s'il va expliquer ça je suis
très amer d on effectivement menacée
c'est compliqué on a exfiltré les
candidats de l'hôtel on a dû partir avec
les escorte policière jusqu'à l'aéroport
donc je pense que c'est effectivement ça
semble très compliqué mais renvoie là il
m'a dit j'espère il me dit j'espère
qu'un jour on aura l'autre version donc
je compte on croit toujours là
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à vous et grâce
à voilà donc moi je vous dis moi c'est
thibault il va expliquer sage pour
l'instant il ya une vie à une enquête et
pour vous répondre sur la drogue et
l'alcool dans effectivement la vérité c
est évident un fléau
c'était un fléau chez nous c'était un
fléau chez nous lors de ces créatures et
parce qu'effectivement on a les
tendances nous on va pas à ne pas
contrôler l'alcool et sont les deux gros
dérapage secrète dans secret story
il y avait même un jour vous aviez faire
secret c'était doc gynéco je ne bois pas
je ne fais que ça et j'ai même vous
dites est vrai qu on est des gros
dérapage en chine fait qu'on est
évidemment les toucher parce qu'à
l'époque et pas forcément la piscine les
réseaux et des moments où il avait des
drames qui se sont noués à cause de
l'alcool ou qu'ils ont effectivement
fait en sorte qu'ils aient moins
d'alcool et quasiment plus c'est vrai
qu'il ya une bouteille je crois pas pour
la soirée et sur la drogue c'est un
fléau également pas se mentir puisque
même sur secret' on aime on a on a on a
démantelé des réseaux puisqu'il faisait
passer de la cam dans les cols de
chemise et sert à quoi donc voilà je
voulais je voudrais alors je vais vous
dire moi et je vais vous dire ce que
disent la production des anges est ce
que dit et quelle est la version de la
production parce que je l'est également
moi je vais l'expliquer lantoine donc ce
serait là pour la production 10 donc lhi
une jeune fille de la production qui est
arrivé elle a commencé à leur dire ne
prenez pas de photos voilà après ça
s'est envenimé le fils du maire aurait
donc un appareil taper le premier c'est
la version de production de cauet on
fait tout ça parce que il y aurait une
guerre entre le maire et le préfet le
préfet qui avait donné l'autorisation
donc à la production de venir tourner à
la région et le maire de saint-andré qui
était complètement confus et donc c'est
pour ça que c'est parti et partez par
aman apparemment d'après la production
les entendre et derrière ils seraient au
centre d'un complot politique
c'est ça j'ai pas dit ça non pas vous
mais lundi il sera au centre d'un
complot politique au sein de la revois
ces fonds auraient voilà donc complot à
la réunion sera donc bientôt sur france
3 en téléfilm pas du tout ce qu'on m'a
dit voilà on est en train de encore une
fois stigmatisé et dire que c'est les
anges qui ont encore non la version
passer pour des idiots et bien sûr un
complot on est des vedettes penser si on
est ce là j'entends depuis
croyez moi et qui a dit ça les gens qui
disent ah non je dis pas que j'ai dit ça
mais ça a été tu es fier c'est encore
une fois on se prend pour des billes
non pas du tout c'est pas ça non je vous
dis moi qui mets remporté sa part à mon
avis ça vous a pas été rapportée comme
ça et si un jour ici c'est moi de les
former aux réformés mais je sais ce que
c'est de la défendre mais raphaël moi
aussi à vous savez on est dans une
émission de débats y en a qui pensent
ainsi qu'un magnum est comme ça et moi
et moi et moi
charmant ils sont rigolos après un
accueil en sang chaud c'est vrai moi si
on débat ça me va c'est juste il ya des
débats c'est normal il ya du contre hier
ce qui s'est passé moi ce que j'ai vu en
tout cas derrière mon écran c'était plus
un acharnement que c'est l'art tout le
monde disait mais non mais donc moi je
veux dire à partir de gmail fils moi
aujourd'hui j'essaye d'être le plus
juste possible bien sûr je suis pas en
train de dire que joe bédié est un
menteur ou quoi que ce soit j'essaie
d'apporter des faits qui m'ont été
l'heureux l'a fait d'accord à partir de
ce moment là hier tout le monde autour
de cette table quasiment a fait un
jugement
oulala c'est la violence des anges ouh
là là ils ont peut-être pris de la
drogue
houle ça a été que des jugements c'est
sûr au final rien c'est au fond les gens
c'est dire dans cette rivière en vain
c'est à dire que effectivement vous me
dites que vous êtes en train de faire un
débat et je n'en pense à l odeur de
chair sur les gens et des
téléspectateurs c'est le jugement que
tout le monde a eu hier soir en disant
ben peut-être qu'ils étaient drogués
pays a connu des violences à la france
et bien tu sois là actuel d'aversion
dans sa version on la retient et roule
dit voilà c'est que et c'est benjamin
est d'accord avec toi il a eu donc le
producteur c'est que voilà vous avez été
vous même agressé lundi
il ya quelqu'un qui me dit un truc très
drôle voilà il ya
le grand frère pascal le grand frère qui
voudrait intervenir dans les airs voilà
ce qu'on dit c'est vrai ça serait avec
plaisir je vous jure que c'est vrai ça
serait drôle producteurs mais ce serait
ça serait très drôle qu'on mette pascal
le confrère dans les anges fêté il ya un
autre pote qui m'a dit ils n'ont qu'à
tourner les anges sur le terrain vague
de district z
[Rires]